it's 5 25 into Monday morning what's
driving you crazy well if you have
turning signal problems the Regional
Transportation Commission wants to hear
from you
fewer Patrick writes the left turn light
from eastbound Cheyenne to go north on
Nellis lasts about four seconds if
you're behind a semi you'll be waiting
for the next Green also getting off
southbound I-15 to go east on Cheyenne
that light stays red for a long time
I've seen drivers just say screw it and
run the red light
so this answer is not just for Patrick
because we got a lot of emails about
signal issues so here's the deal the RTC
wants you to let them know about it we
got their phone number
702-901-8400 if you don't have time to
write that down don't worry about it it
is in the online version of this story
on our website when you click traffic
and then driving you crazy buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
phone and join the driving you crazy
conversation at traffic 8 at
8newsnow.com